a lot of times self-development is just
you know think positive manifest but
sometimes if you've had significant
trauma in your history and you've never
really dealt with that and your your
negative selft talk goes very deep it's
hard to just you know stop saying that
like stop saying I'm a loser or
something I'm not worthy I differentiate
uh negative selft talk and Core
Connections so negative selft talk we
all have and you can change those you
you know something triggers me and that
I'm not smart like I can get rid of it
pretty quickly everybody thinks they
know how to think but with the mentally
strong method we're teaching you how to
make connections from where all those
thoughts are coming from including
spiritual conflict which nobody talks
about all right well we're here with
Christie new member of Mastermind
welcome aboard yeah and we're doing some
one-on-one time together so what's on
your mind how can I help I joined
Mastermind because you are the you know
Guru in YouTube but also just there's
some things that you said in the book
that really resonated with me of being
able to build an Empire that helps
people I've been watching you from a
distance for a couple years and just
been really impressed with your
authenticity and just want to get on
that growth path of building an empire M
I have a pretty good foundation I don't
know how much of my story that you know
but as I was raising my seven kids and
going through
tragedy after tragedy after tragedy I
developed what I call the mentally
strong method we now use it in our
Clinic we see over 120 patients a day
7,000 patients are being helped with the
mentally strong method we are licensing
our model to other psychiatric nurse
practitioners so we have kind of a
licensing model I developed um you know
teach you know courses and one's called
discover the mentally strong method one
is Raising mentally strong kids we've
got a coach coaching course we've got
this whole Academy set up and ready to
launch I've been doing YouTube for about
4 years and just kind of watching how
you just get out there get the content
out and been doing just thought
leadership stuff started doing the
things that you have in in the movement
makers course so we just started the bis
Dev show so we only have like two up
okay started the demonstrate the process
which is very different um because it is
kind of this mapping protocol and it's
this formula and you can visually see it
it's not just um coaching back and forth
so I have a good foundation just really
need that uh Community where you can
actually grow you know one of the things
that a lot of people talk about is don't
be the smartest person in the room don't
you know surround yourself with people
and I don't know how to meet people that
I should be meeting you know I'm a
caretaker I've always been a caretaker
I've never been an entrepreneur I didn't
wake up you know as a kid oh I want to
own my own business some kickass things
though here christe you know well I'm
actually pretty good at it but I never
knew that that's what I was going to do
but you know caretakers have a hard time
in the business realm Y and one of the
best parts about learning my word uh my
word is care and same with with Nina my
wife so but what happens when you try to
start a business people tell you well
you can't care about everybody you know
people aren't going to like you you you
know and I I do care I care if somebody
likes me or not and what was so powerful
for me in knowing that that was my word
it was like you know what I do care and
that person just stabbed me in the back
and but I can admit that it hurts
because I care rather than saying what
people told me to say of like you just
can't care yeah but I do you know I
think it's a superpower yeah I think
it's how you win like I think even how
you develop your whole process is
because you care so much yeah yeah and
and that ultimately comes you know you
struggled and suffered uff a lot on your
journey and now you want other people to
not struggle and suffer as much as you
did like if you had that methodology at
the beginning oh my gosh how much grief
would have would have solved yeah the
other thing that happens in in mental
health is that people focus on mental
illness and nobody none of us want to be
there right but the the reality is is
we're all on a mental health Journey
whether you admit it or not whether
you're doing healthy things to promote
it people are just focusing on mental
illness and I'm trying to get separate
or or Branch out into the mental health
space or away from feif for service bace
right so you know we make good money
I've uh replaced my salary I don't have
to uh actually see patients and those
kinds of things and it's mental health
and prevention that I'm trying to get
into and nobody funds that so right now
the clinic is funded by insurance we
take insurance we're reimbursed by
Insurance have you thought of an option
though like have you you given people an
option how many people have gone through
you're going through 100 something a day
mhm have you offered to anybody so It's
tricky because when you are accepting
Insurance you can't be selling something
on top of that when you're accepting
government insurance so afterwards you
can't uh no not the subsidized
government insurance which is 60% of the
population in um in our current CL so
what does that look like like if I came
in and I came through government
insurance mhm I can't get an and I'm
done and I work with you for five weeks
or however long I work with you the next
week I couldn't if you sent an email to
say hey we're doing this you couldn't do
that yeah if they uh opt into the email
list okay yes um but it's also the
government insurance is typically the
lower income it's not really the um so
it's it's again that caretaker model of
um I want to
care for less fortunate but how do I get
into the space of people who will pay
for how many people have been through
your program total the actual course and
paid for it no just been through even if
it's through Insurance oh close to 7,000
so there's different models right the
there's first off it's getting
everybody's permission to send them
emails MH uh I don't know if you're
already doing that or not but we are
perfect next is categorizing people by
their ability to work with you or not
like there's always something if you
care about people there's always
something you can do for them it's just
levels of access to you and your team go
up with pricing so somebody who can't
afford anything anything anything send
them to YouTube videos right right I
mean that's free like people you help
them in these traumatic moments and you
help them deal with the grief and the
stress and the impact that that's having
on their entire life right not like them
and their family and their kids and
their entire life and that's super
valuable and they're not done
growing and healing right unfortunately
right it's like it's a lifetime Journey
right and so like you've given them some
tools but that's not it right like you
help them with a specific problem and
set them up with a new way of thinking
that they can continue to apply but it's
not like they never ever would need you
guys again and if you actually care
about them then being in their life more
would help them right even if it's free
YouTube videos y you know how many times
you give people a tool or technique and
they it helps them while they're with
you and then a year later something
comes up and they're back to who they
were and completely forgot how to use
the technology that you gave them MH but
if they're seeing even just your face on
a YouTube thumbnail it's like oh yeah
they taught us how to do this yeah just
that reminder is a trigger back to
positive Association right every video
you make every thumbnail that pops up is
a positive trigger to
hope to tools and technologies that they
can use because they're probably
constantly negatively triggered by
everything around them well one of the
things I learned in business and this is
another reason I'm here is like I have
to do it myself I have to set up the
system um we've been through four
marketing companies all of which have
taken close to 250,000 from me over over
four years and gotten us nowhere we have
no solid email campaign I mean we send
out an email when when we're doing
something but we don't have the right um
funnels and things like that um so I
mean YouTube videos through email is an
easy place to start and that's for
everybody and why I say that is because
it allows you to care for people at
every level so it's not oh only if
you're going to pay uh yep $10,000 am I
going to care about you right we care
about everybody but the level of service
you provide is different but we're still
going to care about you and that's where
content really helps so content isn't
just for new people coming in it's for
your current clients who've been through
your process and then they need help and
support again mhm that's an easy enough
thing to do is like hey every week or
how often you doing videos oh I put a
thought leadership video on every week
okay so every week you send an email off
to the people who oped it in with the
lesson from the video and say here watch
this like that's an easy thing to start
I'd love to see a high tier program to
start and we can do some we can do lots
in between but free and then high high
ticket and then you work out the middle
the middle stuff is the hardest because
it requires the most amount of funnels
and team and everything else selling
something at $50 a month is a lot harder
to maintain than something at higher
level right so if somebody's been
through your program what does a year of
working with you look like and maybe not
you Christie but year working with one
of your what of the counselors or yeah
in mental health not mental and see
that's the thing is in the clinic for
insurance to pay for it there has to be
a diagnosis right so completely
different population yes we just got the
website set up where the the course is
online and we have a three tier you know
just the online course the online course
with you know a couple coaching sessions
and then the higher tier uh has coaching
sessions and then two sessions with me
doing the pre um like the treatment
planning and and kind of where you're
going to go and how much is that one
6,000 so 6,000 gets me two sessions with
you plus eight sessions with a coach and
the online course for uh a year depends
on how long someone takes to do it right
it's the uh if you wanted to come to the
clinic and have that live uh over the
course of a week you could do that or if
you wanted to stretch it out um it's
about I can teach the course in eight
hours but to really kind of uh resonate
with it probably a week of if you were
like really focusing on it what's
generally helpful is tell people what to
do okay because if you leave the
opposite of my last coach I just wanted
to tell you okay uh we just paid 20,000
for hooko and they said never tell
anybody what to do which right I
disagreed with but I'm just saying like
this is the industry though that you
know like you're the expert I don't know
what to do I've just been through these
are people who've been through your your
therapy coaching I don't know what what
counseling we call it Counseling in the
clinic perfect um and we're trying to
train up coaches I think every coach
should know this technique because it's
not that hard and it allows
for you to really get to a mental health
plan for someone so what is the plan
like like a personal trainer I go with
my goals I say I want to do this what
does a personal trainer do gives me a
plan right gives me a meal plan gives me
a workout plan holds me accountable if
I'm going to stick to the plan or not
like give people a mental health plan
because your confidence in the plan is
the thing that gives me confidence in
the plan if you leave it up to me it's
like do it at your own pace and do
whatever you like most people are not
going to do anything you might have the
I mean your data will show you but most
people just won't do anything okay
because you just left it to them right
and this is a struggle point for them y
so they want to know that this is going
to work and they want to be told what to
do they want to be told by somebody
trusted what to do right you're coming
here because you want to be told by
somebody trusted what to do yes you want
me to give you a plan yes every I said I
don't know Christie like do whatever you
want to do it's like why don't I come to
Toronto to do this thing are you kidding
me
Carmichael yeah right like do this yes
so that's what they want from you
they've just you have an intimate
relationship with these people they've
just told you like their deepest darkest
secrets and fears and you held their
hand through the maybe the toughest time
in their life and you AKA all the coach
right counselors trying to get the lingo
the counselor is on your team right and
so what happens next and they may not be
able to to afford what happens next
right but what happen and what happens
next doesn't necessarily even need to
involve you what happens next could
involve
them and I don't know what an effective
thing looks like what an effective
treatment looks like that's why you need
to tell me what I need to do next yeah
based on what you're doing now here's
what we recommend yeah and I like
looking at annual programs okay so what
is a year working with you guys look
like you can always come back from it oh
I can't afford a year that's too much
commitment okay well here's a here's a
three-month plan or a six-month plan but
you default to a year of mental Wellness
we've just been through this mental
healing and Trauma now we're focused on
Mental Health and Wellness right for the
next year and that costs $6,000 or
$112,000 or whatever and here's what you
get for that yeah you get two sessions
with christe she's our founder she's the
creator of this program and that's going
to happen on month one and month six to
help you introduce you to it and to help
make sure that you're on track and
keeping progress you're going to get
three sessions with me and that's going
to be month two and like whatever and
I'm not I'm just pull making stuff up no
and I'm thinking the details as you're
you're talking but it's all about that's
the language that needs to shift is like
we are going to make the plan for you
like based on just tell me what to do
yeah and and from a caring loving place
right like not just money grubbing
trying to rip people off what will
actually help this person get to mental
health in the next 6 to 12 months right
yep what is required for that person mhm
you know hopefully if I if I stick to my
workout plan and I stick to my meal plan
I'm going to I'm going to be leaner and
have better health numbers right like
right I I should feel I should feel
mentally in a much better place if I
follow your plan yep so what do I
naturally need to do and then there's an
option with Christie and there's an
option without Christie and with
Christie is going to be a lot more than
without Christie that program with your
7,000 people again there only be a
percentage to take you up on it but like
I would launch with that to start to
recoup all the money that you've lost
on invested invested into marketing
coaches or whatever it's invested in
learning right because because courses
and memberships and everything else is
great and Community the community that
goes with that is the best part of it
that I get to be with other people who
also are on their mental health Journey
right that's great so it's not just the
counselors who are helping me but it's
also the community and each other but
it's a lot of work to create and you're
not making a ton per person it's the
most scalable thing cuz time with
Christie is right you're going to run
out of spaces
right so it's usually let's make some
money to then fund the team to be able
to support the mid- tier thing which
then is where we get ultimate scale
right so YouTube is free high-end is the
the wellness program or the mental
health program or what you want to call
it but what does a year look like that
you can then bring back to 6 months or 3
months if you need to but in in honesty
like they will they would be better
served if they work with you for a year
MH your counselors are probably the only
positive thing they have in their
environment like you're the ones pulling
them plucking them from this terrible
environment and helping them see hope
because their friends and their family
probably aren't super supportive and if
they are they don't know what to say and
they're triggered by their own issues
and insecurities and everything else so
you're plucking them from this terrible
environment and showing them hope and a
brighter potential future if you do that
for a year versus 3 months you're going
to get better results mhm right now
maybe they can't afford it so it's not
try to sell somebody something they
can't afford right but if they can
afford it you're going to better serve
them by being with them for a longer
period than a limited window okay right
or no do you don't believe that you have
feel I believe it in my mind and I could
be wrong so I'm I'm trying to receive
what you're saying in my mind I'm trying
to separate from
illness and
and and help people like the culture is
messed up like very few people are on a
mental health Journey very people are
living in um turmoil and not getting
help because they don't want a mental
illness diagnosis right uh and just the
the population that we see in the clinic
is typically very sick 95% are on
medication um and then you have to be
careful
of your personal license and if you're
doing coaching that's cash and you're
they're also getting medication from you
the the legality of that is is a little
different too so in my mind and I'm not
saying this is right in my mind I was
going to be marketing to a different
population
for those packages you can you just
building from SC Scratch versus you
already have these people who you have
help who percentage of them MH are on
meds uh or have very complicated
situations and have no budget and won't
be ideal clients for you which is fine
but 70 MH like is 1% right yeah and
their families like too so a lot of
times you know um the people that are
actually following us and getting the
emails and watching us on our YouTube
are the family members of people that
are coming they might want to them do it
for themselves and like even the idea
that you're doing a mental
you're doing a mental health and
wellness program as opposed to just
you've been diagnosed with having a
mental illness right starts to spread
like what do you mean well how are you
doing this starts to spread you help one
person they can share but if out of your
7,000 you had 70 1% who say okay yeah
that's a fit for me yeah whatever
assessments they have to go through of
not just can they afford it but is it
too complicated a case can you actually
care is it going to do service to them
we're not just trying to take their
money but like can we actually help them
right if you sign up 70 people you you
couldn't handle 70 people at your $6,000
package it's a lot of Christy time right
I mean maybe you want to do that it's
going to be a lot of yeah you've worked
yourself out of the practice and now
you're like right back in with 70 people
that you got to oh my gosh I got to meet
these people twice 140 sessions that now
you have to do yeah so it's something
you can't do new as well right just is
there a percentage that would say yes
from the people that you're already
serving and I guess the and we can work
through this over the next couple days
is like how do you actually send those
emails do you just send one I mean we've
sent like random emails we've had
marketing companies even do um you know
paid stuff around you know people that
are already following us online and
things like that and we get we've gotten
zero return on investment so we're doing
something wrong either the way that
we're wording it
um something we're doing something wrong
even books that are only $16 to $50 we
have not been successful
in at any scale I mean a book here and
there but well it's making sure that you
have all the emails and they're actually
being you know sent out properly um
deliverability is probably one of the
issues there like even if you had crappy
copy these are customers of yours
already right they've already been
through even if it was on insurance
they're still yeah you should be getting
well and we've gotten a lot from just
people you um following us on YouTube
yeah and then you know joining the email
list and things like that too a lot of
grieving mothers um that that uh have
you know are on that email list if
there's specific scenarios that work
that you can integrate a year-long care
plan for example grieving mothers right
so you help them through their trauma
but it's like that it's still not just
gone forever right so what is a
year-long program look like maybe part
of that is
on you know on the on the anniversary of
the child's death and on the birthday of
the child they're on a call with you
right cuz what are the two most
triggering dates for people going to be
yeah it's supposed to be his 19th
birthday today MH and like when are they
most likely to slip back into all their
padds and everything right but they get
a call with you it's like it's a
reminder you remind them of the tools
and the hope and the and if it's not you
then it's one of there one of your
counselors and I'm not in the space but
I would guess that those two dates are
like pretty important dates and they
might need some extra care and support
right on those days yeah the thing
that's changing in my mind as you talk
is really that kind of the year programs
is what people are going to to need
especially after losing a child going in
the Christmas yeah you know or whatever
their holidays are for their religion
you know it's something you can ask
right like oh this would would have been
Billy's 20th Christmas or whatever right
right again it's a customized plan for
the scenarios that you you see the same
20 cases kind of on repeat with some
weird super weird outliers but on the
ones that you know like how do you
design a custom plan for that person
right you know like a personal trainer
wouldn't give a man and a woman the
exact same thing wouldn't give a 6'2 guy
and a 5'8 or 5 foot2 guy or whatever
like the same plan would pound guy and a
160 guy you know it's like it's a
customized plan MH but imagine something
and again if you could tie it not just
to strategy and business and like money
but to caring because that's how you're
going to win right right like imagine if
the mother care you want to not charge
people and I know I have to well but
it's both right but like it's also those
like when you're thinking about money it
feels cold and calculated and not caring
enough so it's like the you have to mix
both right but not just be cold and
calculated not just be caring it's in
it's in the mix so yeah like imagine if
a grieving mom a year later on the
anniversary of the death or the birth
got a call from you mhm how much does
that help her in that moment right
probably a lot you're probably not going
to get oh was it his birthday I don't
even remember that like probably not
right no matter how much work you they
even answer the phone right so it's like
if you know they're not pick up the
phone we do the day before M tomorrow is
going to be his birthday let's prepare
let's let's whatever tools you need to
walk through right yeah yeah that's a
really good idea cuz you know she's
going to be thinking about that and it's
going to be stressful and so like that's
the ultimate care that you can provide
worst case you send the video right you
can automate it's okay on the on the
15th of July send this video MH so even
if they can't afford to be on your so
there's solutions for every price range
but the ultimate one would be to get a
call from you right now do you want to
be talking to groovy mothers every day
the day before they're child's birthday
like that takes a toll on the caretaker
as well yeah and so maybe it's not
always you or maybe it's somebody else
on team but even just thinking through
what those plans would be it's part of a
ongoing mental
health um Journey because we're never
done right and it's great that you help
people we're never done I'm never done
you're never done it's an it's always a
process yeah but if you know the things
that are going to trigger them like
that's when that's when they might have
had a great year but then the they comes
around and then they kill themselves MH
yeah no suicide is huge in grieving
parents for sure in the moment which
you're dealing with but then also at
those anniversary dates or other other
dates that might have maybe that's part
of the intake is like what dates are
significant to you right maybe there's
some religious holiday that means a lot
to them you know or the first day they
move to the country or whatever you know
like what are the triggering moments and
then those are the dates that they're
going to get we're going to call we're
going to I'm going to call you the day
of the day before
yeah I'll get on that right away that I
think that's a uh we have a large
following um and never we're talking to
people like if you think if you look
through your I mean you don't know all
the people at 7,000 it's a lot of your
counselors doing the work but in the
emails messaging people and saying we're
thinking about this if you're interested
in a here's some of the ideas that we
have MH or if you already know what
people need then you just create it and
say we're launching this
thing yeah and so grieving mothers is
one category or like what's another
category just people who
are lacking confidence they have you
know one of the things that the mentally
strong method does that the the
self-development space doesn't have is
kind of separating what's holding you
back a lot of times you know in the
self-development is just you know think
positive manifest like do do do it's all
action but sometimes you know if you are
you know if you've had significant
trauma in your history and and you've
never really dealt with that and your
your negative selft talk goes very deep
it's hard to just you know stop saying
that like stop saying I'm a loser stop
saying I'm not worthy you know if that
came from childhood trauma it's not
always that easy to just you know change
the the dialogue and I
differentiate uh negative selft talk and
Core Connections so negative selft talk
we all have right it's you know and and
you can change those you you know
something triggers me and that I'm not
smart and I go of course I'm smart like
I've gotten this far right like I can
get rid of it pretty quickly right right
I'm not an entrepreneur yeah and I'm
like well I've been pretty good at it
but I've done I've done pretty well you
know but those are negative selft talk
The Core Connections go so deep yeah um
and being able to recognize Core
Connections because there there's a lot
more emotional charge to them they
probably are not going to just go away
with success like they're going to stay
in there like so one of my Core
Connections is you're not good enough
and so that is actually fueled some of
My Success right trying to prove that I
am good enough like but you know when
something happens and that that gets
pushed you know it it's a deeper
emotional charge it's probably never
going to go away with just external uh
success like you have to take the time
to do those emot
disconnects um so those you know Core
Connections addictions um you know is a
whole separate category that is very
complicated so the mentally strong
method is think organize and choose
everybody thinks they know how to think
right but with the mentally strong
method we're teaching you how to make
connections from where all those
thoughts are coming from including
spiritual conflict which nobody talks
about it's like uh you know the culture
of of you not allowed to prze not
allowed to you know tell people you know
what faith to have but then we have a
whole culture of people who have no
faith and there's a lot of spiritual
conflict people who are like oh you know
I prayed to God for this and you know
horrible things happened and I I
personally struggled with praying for
you know my children and they and they
pass away right so and we don't talk
about that but it is directly connected
to our mental health and it and when you
have those spiritual conflicts well
whether you believe in a God or don't
believe in a God you are a soul and
there is something outside of you and if
we and everyone should own that and kind
of work that out yeah and we don't talk
about it right because it's like one of
these things that you know uh we're
not everyone is scared that the other
person will think that I'm trying to get
them to believe what I believe right and
and um we are uh mental physical and
spiritual being means and I really
encourage people
to go on that Journey whatever that is
for them yeah I mean it's very clear
from you talking it's much more than
just mental illness yeah and you're
excited I mean you're help you're loving
helping people through the little
traumatic moment but it's like you're
deeply passionate helping them create a
plan for the rest of their lives well
and just revolutionize the the culture
of of mental health like we we still
like there was this big anti-stigma
movement right but it was anti-stigma
too
disease processed to someone who has a
mental illness but what about everyone
the man search for meaning by Victor
Frankle I mean I think everyone in the
self-development world has has read that
book but it is so true and we've lost a
lot of that that you know just hope by
itself will make you healthier more
successful and um we can be resilient to
anything but we don't teach how to do
that we just say well well if you if
you're not resilient then you end up
with a mental illness right but um we
can actually teach resilience we can
teach it to kids I have a raising
mentally strong kids curriculum um and
course and like we can actually start
teaching these things before somebody um
gets to that point of of clinical
depression and anxiety and that kind of
stuff so pretty passionate I love I love
your heart and this is going to be
exciting to build yeah for people who
want to check you out where are they
going to go
mentally strong
academy.com we'll put it in the
description below all right perfect
christe thank you for the love very much
very much to watch me coach another
Mastermind member oneon-one check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there it's inspiring to see
and a woman from Norway betting on
herself to to do these things and so
showing the journey and any self-doubt
you might have this is why I went to
Toronto you know like most people won't
do this kind of thing